alerte pour les uns à confirmation pour
les autres al qaida cible directement la
france
la dernière vidéo d'ayman al zawahiri a
été intégralement visionner et le bras
droit de ben laden brandi la menace
indirecte de nouveaux attentats de la
part du gspc un groupe salafiste
algérien affiliés à al qaïda laurent
boussier alain d'ubs à semer la peur
dans le coeur des traîtres et des
apostats français
lundi dernier pour la troisième fois en
trois ans à ayman al zawahiri menace est
donc directement la france d'attentats
terroristes prétexte connu la sphère du
voile à l'école
la présence française en afghanistan et
plus récemment le soutien de la france
au déploiement d'une force
internationale au libre
nouveauté le lieutenant de ben laden
désigne son bras armé contre notre pays
le gspc un mouvement terroriste algérien
surtout actif dans le maghreb et dont
les liens avec al qaïda sont connus
depuis plusieurs années cette menace
concernant
des frappes contre les intérêts français
les doit être prise en sérieux d'abord
en algérie où le gspc
malgré ses déboires dispose encore d'un
appareil opérationnelle qui pourrait se
transformer en des projections sur le
territoire français ou sur l'ensemble de
l'europe occidentale
une situation évidemment prise très au
sérieux par les autorités il ya bien une
situation de risque ce qui doit
évidemment nous conduire en permanence
depuis plusieurs mois les services de
renseignement français ont constaté une
réactivation des contacts entre
sympathisants du gspc en france et dans
plusieurs pays d'europe en alerte rouge
depuis mars 2004
le plan vigipirate est maintenu à son
niveau habituel
le message d'al zawahiri n'a pas
déclenché de mesures particulières